[Music]
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america
let's find out what happened the
president of mexico asked president
biden this week to share some of
america's coronavirus vaccine supply
can we also get some said americans
the senate yesterday began debating
president biden's 1.9 trillion dollar
corona
virus relief package or as it'll be
known when they're done
the 17.50 relief package
we are lucky to have it yeah
a new mexico man reportedly tried to
smuggle 277 pounds of bologna into the
united states in his car
that's a lot of baloney said women about
andrew cuomo's apology
toy company hasbro received backlash
last week after they announced that
they're dropping the mister
from their popular mr potato head
playset in an effort to be more
inclusive but if you ask me that's too
inclusive
because if there's one thing i know
about potatoes it's
[Music]
potatoes
[Music]
potatoes are boys they have and balls
potatoes can't be girls cause they don't
hang out in mall
if you think veggies can't be gendered
then you have failed
spuds have a gender and that gender is
male
[Music]
potatoes
[Music]
potatoes
the archdiocese of new orleans recently
told catholics that the new johnson and
johnson coronavirus vaccine is
morally compromised so they're
recommending that it be transferred to a
new
parish pepsi this week began selling a
new line of cocktail mixers marketed to
consumers
between 21 and 34 years old
i'll have to check those out said
exclusively 16 year olds
in an upcoming interview with oprah
duchess meghan markle says
life in britain's royal family was quote
almost
unsurvivable i don't know if anything it
seems
too survivable
maybe we will be here forever
as old as the wind
there you see that mountain yeah i'm
older than that
i was there when it was created
i remember god
is a son of mine god save the queen
who's also a relative
according to a recent study black female
characters in family films are more
likely to have jobs in science
engineering or math than female
characters of other races
they're also 100 percent more likely to
use those skills to help a white woman
fall in love
[Music]
mandy it turns out that you and brian
are 85 percent compatible
what go get em girl i will
here's my favorite scarf boy oh boy
she sure does no dudes
dr seuss enterprises announced this week
that they will stop the sale of six dr
seuss books that show racist imagery and
one that shows a fox that's practically
naked that's right dr seuss enterprises
announced they will stop the sale of six
dr seuss books that show racist imagery
including his most popular book
oh the places you better go back to
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh the neighborhoods i won't go into
oh the woman i almost hired
[Laughter]
oh can i touch your hair
[Laughter]
oh the you must be good at basketball
oh we could do this forever that was the
monologue
that was it that was our monologue tarek
did you like the monologue
i did good i wrote it just for you
oh yeah so when christmas comes you
better not say nothing
now some of you may have noticed tarik
has been gone for a couple of weeks
tarik where have you been do you want a
real answer or a happy answer that won't
make you sad
happy answer out loud real answer in
writing uh like they used to do in
silent movies
yeah okay where have i been
i took some me time
oh yeah what did your me time entail
amazon splurges bubble baths movie
marathons
sounds like heaven it was heaven
you sure do know how to relax got any
advice for people on how to unwind
oh yes i have some advice here's my
advice
i don't want you to get too stressed
it could easily happen to you it
happened to me and i
always take time for fun
[Music]
i party i visit my friends i love a
cocktail
and even i ended up in need of some mita
so i'm begging you treat yourself
[Music]
if you're currently taking some me time
good for you
and if you know someone who has taken
some me time tell them
good job
that's great anything else yes if you
live in texas
[Music]
howdy
good advice we're happy to have you back
we love you so bad
love you too now speaking of covid we're
about to hit the one-year mark of the
coronavirus pandemic
and for a lot of people that anniversary
brings with it a giant wave of anxiety
so we'd like to help you relieve a
little bit of that anxiety
with a segment called the cool
down relax
breathe think happy thoughts about
a sunrise a cool breeze
a platter of sizzling fajitas
kids jumping rope in front of an open
fire hydrant getting an old dried-up pen
to write again a tiny hat
on the biggest man you've ever seen in
your
life an extra candy bar
coming out of the vending machine
someone admitting they're wrong without
getting
defensive disney and pixar's
up but without the first few minutes
you know the ones a movie that's exactly
90 minutes long a fact you made up
turning out to be correct
the phrase oh wow she usually doesn't
let people pet her
i guess she likes you
a bag of m ms that's only the green ones
putting on an old coat and finding that
chapstick
you were looking for a man saying
not to be racist but and then
slipping on a banana peel
a constant stream of compliments on a
big swing you took with your hair
really good gossip about somebody you
barely know finally
figuring out the name of that song you
heard years ago
it was freak a leak congratulations
your anxiety is gone but after the break
we'll still be here
see you in a second i have my own
youtube channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this
[Music]
[Applause]